herr scholz wir sprechen jetzt über die
verschärfung und das wird eben das große
thema der folgende woche werden
erleichtert hat sie ganz klar jetzt
gestern nochmal bekannt für
verschärfungen unterstützen sie dies es
müssen weitere maßnahmen ergriffen
werden wir sehen jetzt aktuelle zahlen
die deutlich machen dass die maßnahmen
die wir ergriffen haben sogar wirkung
zeigen die inzidenz werte gehen leicht
zurück in einigen bundesländern mehr in
anderen nur sehr sehr wenig aber das
heißt ja nur dass maßnahmen wirken und
dass das gerücht ist das alles
überflüssig seien falsch ist
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass wir noch
nicht so weit sind wie wir eigentlich
gekommen sein wollten und wir müssen in
rechnung stellen dass die mutation die
mit dem virus jetzt geschieht an
mehreren stellen wenn sie in deutschland
ankommen und in großem maße ankommen
auch ganz dramatische wirkung
hinterlassen können das wird nochmal
morgen erörtert mit wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern zusammen aber ich
glaube ist will der sollte erörtert das
erst mal richtige daten über diese
mutation da weiß man ja nicht viel
drüber wir werden unterschiedliche
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
hören und die daten erörtern
aber um ihre frage zu beantworten ja ich
glaube es wird auch weitere maßnahmen
geben müssen
sie haben gerade mitbekommen dass in
österreich der dortige lockdown ein
wenig verlängert worden ist das werden
wir sicher auch machen gehe davon aus
dass das schon 14 tage sein können die
noch mal dazu kommen und wir werden
sicherlich auch darüber diskutieren
müssen dass man bei den home offices
nicht bei appellen bleibt wir müssen da
noch einen schritt weiter machen denn im
frühjahr haben viel mehr arbeitgeber
ihren beschäftigten die möglichkeit zu
hause zu arbeiten einen zug geworfen wo
das licht und das muss jetzt glaube ich
auch intensiver gemacht nichts im
home-office wollen sie durchsetzen am
dienstag es wird immer darauf ankommen
dass das betrieblich auch geht wir
wollen ja pragmatisch bleiben und nichts
unmögliches verlangen
aber ich glaube dass das schon ein
beitrag sein kann für eine kurze zeit
dazu beizutragen dass die kontakte
reduziert werden übrigens ja dann nicht
nur am arbeitsplatz sondern auch bei dem
weg von und zur arbeit und das hilft ja
können sie beispiele nennen also wer ich
habe den eindruck immer ganz viele sind
schon im home-office die das überhaupt
können ganz viele können es ja nicht
also der arbeiter bei turniers der
arbeiter bei vw der
wird sich schwer tun dass rein zuhause
zu schlachten oder das auto zuhause zu
bauen wo ist es im moment noch möglich
das gilt natürlich vor allem für die
büro bereiche dort auch nicht
flächendeckend dabei ein sehr viel
größerem maße als das jetzt der fall ist
zumal ja auch viele unternehmen die
technischen möglichkeiten dazu
geschaffen haben im laufe des letzten
jahres und nach der ersten außer
konstruiert dass es wegen haltung was
fällt die noch es sind vor allem die
verwaltung die dienstleistungsbereiche
wo man das machen kann und ich will noch
mal sagen es geht eigentlich darum dass
es richtig gemacht so wie jeder sich das
selber überlegen würde wenn er darüber
nachdenkt wie kann man dazu beitragen
dass wir das infektionsgeschehen
reduzieren
und jetzt haben sie viele appelle
gemacht uns berichten viele arbeitnehmer
ein arbeitnehmer das sie gern würden
aber dass das nicht so geschätzt wird
und manche haben auch gehört
wenn es nicht vorgeschrieben ist mache
ich das nicht ich glaube diesen diesen
appell sollten wir hören